سيناريو اخره للانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه وهو ان تفرز فوزا جمهوريا ساحقا
او موجه حمراء وليس صعبا تفسير ذلك مع
تحقيق الجمهوريين مكاسب ثابته في
استطلاعات الراي معدله قبول الرئيس عند
الاربعين المنخفضه مقارنه بمكانه عليه عند
الرؤساء السابقين تتطلب الموجه الحمراء
فقط ان يقرر الناخبون الذين لم يحسموا
امرهم اصواتهم للتعبير عن موقفهم ورايهم
في حزب الرئيس بغض النظر عن مشاعرهم تجاه
شغل المناصيب الديمقراطيه الفرديه او ربما
يتطلب الامر اقبالا جمهوريا قويا على نحو
غير متوقع يوم الانتخابات بينما يبقى
الناخبون الشباب وذوي الاصول الافريقيه
والاسبانيا في منازلهم باعداد اكبر من ما
كان عليه الحال في انتخابات سابقا وقد يجد
حينها شاغل مجلس وبديمقراطيون الامنون
انفسهم في سباقات متقاربه بشكل مدهش في
اقصى الشمال يمكن للج دينا ان يقلب بسهوله
المناطق الرئيسيه في فيرجينيا ونور
كارولينا وسيتقدمون ايضا اكثر في المنطقه
الزرقاء ولن تكون سباقه مجلس الشيوخ في
ولايه تينارت كارولين باوهاي متقاربه وقد
يتجنب الجمهور هنا جوله الاعاده في جورجيا
في سباق مجلس الشيوخ ويفوزون فيديوهات ومن
شان ذلك ان يجعلهم يسيطرون على المجلس